One of the reasons I like doing long
form interviews is that I can really
focus in on important issues with my
guests.
In many cases,
the issues are inextricably connected,
making it easy to go from topic to
topic.
If we're talking about political
correctness,
that's a pretty easy jump to free
speech,
which is then another easy jump to the
regressive left.
Sometimes these jumps just appear when
I'm not looking for them,
and that's usually when the
conversations get really good is the
spaces where you have to think that are
the breeding ground to spark new ideas.
My guest this week is civil rights
attorney and legal expert or Reba
Martin.
I've done the Dr drew show on Hln
several times with Reba and always find
her to be incisive,
thought provoking,
and passionate.
While we've appeared together several
times.
This will be the first time we really
get to flesh out some ideas in a long
form way without worrying about a
commercial break.
A rib and I are going to dive into a ton
of hot topics and big ideas.
This week we're going to discuss
everything from the black lives matter
movement to the war on drugs to the
Oscars,
so white controversy as a Harvard
educated black woman who founded and
manages her own very successful law
firm.
I don't think I could find a better
person to tackle so many important
issues with and arriva.
You see what just happened there?
I just played some identity politics,
didn't I?
Arriva happens to be black and happens
to be a woman,
but in reality,
how is that important to our
conversation?
Actually,
I don't really think it is.
I assume some of her views are based on
her own personal experiences,
but what I care about are her ideas,
not the color of her skin or her gender.
We really have to get over the idea that
by looking at someone,
you can figure out what they're all
about.
I literally could not care less about
someone's skin color or their religion
or their sexuality.
What I care about is their ideas.
What do they believe?
Why do they believe it?
Are they right?
Are they wrong?
What kind of world are they trying to
create?
That is simply all that matters to me.
There are black conservatives out there,
there are Mexican Libertarians,
there are Lesbian Christians and there
are cis gendered,
blue haired video game playing bisexual
quakers,
and if you care about all those labels
more than the ideas that the people
themselves believe in,
then you are actually part of the
problem.
If you truly care about minorities,
then you have to care about minorities
within those minorities.
If you truly care about diversity,
then you have to acknowledge diversity
within diversity itself.
We should be defined by what we believe,
not prejudged by people's assumptions as
a wise man.
Once said,
when you assume you make an ass out of
you and me,
my guest this week is a civil rights
attorney,
legal expert,
and you may have seen us on Dr drew's
couch together,
or Eva Martin.
Welcome to the show.
Good to be here.
You know,
from sitting next to each other to
sitting across from each other.
This is,
it seems that we're going to be
adversaries because we're
usually on a couch right next to each
other.
We get some legs touch.
It helps with some of the crazies that
come on that show and really make it
difficult for people.
I think like you and I who have really
intelligent and smart things to say,
wow,
we're,
uh,
building each other up just as we start
here.
But that's exactly what I wanted to have
you on the show because we've been on Dr
drew a couple of times together and I
always find you,
you're extremely passionate and you know
your stuff.
And I find there's so many people in
television,
especially in Cable News and on the
cable channels that are just yelling and
screaming about stuff but aren't really
experts.
I can tell you,
and not to brag about my background,
but you know,
when you think of an expert,
you really want the person.
I have some credentials that really make
them an expert and I can't tell you how
many times on these shows I've sat next
to someone.
I'm having a conversation,
I want to go,
you know what?
I'm sorry.
I am fifth grade.
It just drives me crazy.
But yes,
there's been this proliferation of quote
unquote experts because there's so many
shows and it seems like if you are
willing to say something so outrageous
and to say it very loudly,
you can get booked on a show.
And that's what we see pretty routinely
on a lot of these shows.
Yeah.
And that is again,
I mean that's why I love working with
you because not only do you know your
shit,
but you get right to it.
So then I'm sitting next to you and I'm
thinking,
man,
if I just had that kind of just incisive
way of going at it.
So we're going to get into some stuff.
Well,
I've been working on TV for a while and
I've had to perfect the soundbite
because oftentimes you get 30 seconds
and I tell you,
I start checking the news at five.
I read seven,
eight newspapers throughout the day and
I'll get a call.
And it's some complex issues that I've
got to go on and talk to millions of
viewers to make them understand
sometimes very technical legal stuff.
And the reality is what's happening to
the courtroom and a a difficult case,
a murder trial doesn't really play well
when you're trying to reduce it to a
32nd sound bite.
So you got to get kind of skilled and
how to bring that very complex
information to really digestible
television viewers.
Yeah.
And that's exactly why I like doing the
long form interview because now we have
an hour or maybe a little bit more even
to really get into some stuff,
really exchange some ideas.
So
for it,
because some of these topics are so big
theater we spend all day talking about,
but yet you've got to reduce it to a
sound bite.
So I love long form conversations
and we're,
we're in the right spot.
But before we get to the issues,
I want to do a little bit on your
history.
So you are.
You're from St Louis originally,
right?
It
was right next to Ferguson,
Missouri.
So when we were all eyes on Ferguson
with the Mike Brown shooting,
it was really personal for me because
not only did I grow up in that
community,
I knew so many of the people that were
involved on the front lines doing the
protest.
So when that happened,
that explosion in that community
occurred really personally for me.
So yes,
from St Louis and went to college in
Chicago,
University of Chicago.
Love Chicago.
Glad I'm not there this weekend though,
given the blizzard that's been just,
you know,
ravishing the comp a country,
you move the right direction.
I moved it right.
It's in the sunshine and then went onto
Harvard.
Uh,
so I lived in Cambridge.
unfortunately the patriots aren't going
to.
Yeah.
And my husband's like
the Patriots,
but uh,
anyhow,
yeah.
So I went to Harvard,
then I actually worked in a corporate
law firm.
I worked on Wall Street and I was in
this major corporate law firm
representing big fortune 500 companies
and doing a lot of corporate law and I
just got tired.
I just stuck.
It.
Didn't fit with my background,
didn't fit with you know,
who I had grown up to be and the people
that had influenced me.
So I left.
I left is really,
really,
really good job.
Yeah.
Are you saying the corporate lawyers
make a lot of money?
Is that what you're saying?
I left a good job with a lot of money
and a lot of perks
and an office like on the 40th floor,
big.
It was amazing.
So imagine me calling St Louis family.
That's like just over the moon with
happiness that first generation college
graduate,
first generation Harvard lawyer,
big corporate law firm.
And now I'm leaving to go work with one
other lawyer in this tiny little office
on Wilshire Boulevard in Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Give up this huge salary.
Uh,
it didn't go over too well.
I can,
you must have felt incredible pressure
because you had sort of accomplished a
lot.
Not,
not that advanced in age.
And then you say,
all right,
I'm going to step away from it.
Isn't that sort of what it's all about
really what life is all about?
And I think it is,
and I think that
folks who find the most happiness in
their careers is because they've taken a
risk and they really follow their
instincts.
They follow their intuition,
they don't do what's on the kind of the
path that's been laid out for them.
And if you go to Harvard and you're in
the top of your class,
your path is supposed to be either you
become a supreme court clerk and you go
on to be a judge or you go and you run a
corporate law for.
You start off as an associate,
you become a partner and you make a ton
of money and that's a great life.
And having lots of friends that do that.
So I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that,
right?
They have a great lifestyles,
but it just wasn't who I was at my core.
I wanted to have more control of who I
represented.
I wanted to represent little people.
I want it to be involved in issues that
really mattered to me.
And I just wanted something different
for my career.
So I had no husband,
had no mortgage and no kids.
So you could walk away from a big job
like that when you don't have all of
those responsibilities.
Yeah.
And now you have a husband.
Oh my God.
You have a law that you run with your
husband,
correct?
Yes.
And you have three kids and all of this
stuff.
So you're doing a lot of fun.
But I'm happy about it.
And about seven years ago I decided I
wanted to step away from my courtroom
practice.
I was a trial lawyer and I wanted to
have a greater impact and I had this
amazing case,
a amazing because I was representing
these great families.
Horrible thing had happened to them.
Their kids had been abused of the
classroom,
some nonverbal autistic kids abusing the
classroom by this just criminal teacher.
Really.
Uh,
and they called me from Las Vegas and
asked me to come and represent them.
And I did that.
And Dr Phil was very interested in their
story and invited my clients and then me
as a result of representing them onto
his show.
And I got there.
I loved having an opportunity to raise
awareness about an issue I cared about
and break down,
you know,
what had happened legally and why this
teacher was being prosecuted and that
began my TV career and I've been working
in TV ever since that one appearance on
Dr Phil.
Yeah,
and even that,
we're going to get to this a little
later,
but even having a case involving autism,
you've written a book about autism.
Your your son has autism.
I don't like saying is autistic because
it seems very defining versus has
autism.
It's just a piece of who he is a so that
even that right there,
it's a nice way to start your adventure
sorta because it was something that was
very important to you.
Yeah,
and you're right.
I did write a book because I was
frustrated.
I didn't like what was out there.
I was too hard to figure out how to you
get the best education.
How do you get the best healthcare,
and I said,
this is crazy.
I'm a Harvard trained lawyer and I'm
having such a difficult time.
What about the mom who has four or five
kids at home,
maybe working two jobs and doesn't have
the time to sit on the Internet all day
like I did,
and search for this information.
So I wrote a book called the everyday
advocate standing up for your child with
autism and other special needs to really
bring a lot of the information that I
had learned as a parent and as an
advocate and as a lawyer into one place
that apparent a professional could go
and get the help that they need for
their child or grandchild or whatever.
So really just tried to make that
journey a little easier for parents.
Okay.
All right,
well we're going to dive a little deeper
into that in a bit,
but let.
Let's knock out some issues.
Okay.
So you already brought up the first
thing that I wanted to discuss with you,
which is black lives matter.
So as you said,
you're from St Louis,
right next to Ferguson.
You know this area.
A couple of weeks ago I had larry elder
on who is,
who is the eye roll already.
Was that side eye or eye roll?
It was
fit on his radio show.
We've debated these issues a lot.
Uh,
I don't understand Larry,
to be honest with you.
Bright Guy,
lawyer,
a turn,
talk show hosts radio talk show host.
But his views are the most extreme
views.
I can't even imagine where he got them.
So,
so I don't wanna I don't wanna make this
about him.
It's not necessary,
but the reason I mentioned it is because
a why I liked doing the shows.
I want to talk to people that believe
one thing and somebody that believes
something else.
So that's a great place for us to start
because basically his take,
I don't want to put words in his mouth,
but to paraphrase him was he felt that
there really is no more systemic racism
in the United States and that,
that really the struggle for the black
community is because of the breakdown of
the family.
So if you want to address that a little
bit and then we can dive right into
really the nuts and bolts of the stupid.
I thought
really it can be more articulate about
it,
but I'm just going to say that's stupid
a to say there's no longer systemic
racism.
Just ignore so much data,
so many statistics,
so many reports,
uh,
just,
it ignores the fact that ignores the
reality and conservatives like Larry,
like to deflect from those issues
because if they can blame it on the
family,
if they can blame it on the victims and
they don't have to accept any
responsibility.
But the reality is the criminal justice
system,
let's just start there.
Disproportionate number of African
Americans and Latinos,
but particularly blacks who are
incarcerated who have longer sentences,
who are treated differently,
everything from driving while black.
So who are racially profiled even when
they drive their cars.
And we've seen so many examples of this
from high profile people like Chris
Rock.
Oh,
James Blake,
the tennis player who all have had some
negative experience.
The President Eric holder,
when he was attorney general,
talked about him and his brother being
stopped in,
in Washington.
So
Danny Glover,
something happened with Danny Glover.
He couldn't get a cab or something.
I don't think we could identify a black
man serious,
whether they're high profile celebrity
professional or just the guy on the
street that hasn't had some negative
experience with the police simply
because of their race.
So when folks like Larry Talk about,
you know,
we're post racial society,
the facts are off.
There's this wrong.
So what would you say about the family
part though?
Because there,
it seems to me that as I say on the show
all the time,
two things can be true at once.
So everything that you've said,
they're fully make sense to me,
but also that the breakdown of the
family in general,
black,
white,
Asian,
green is,
is a problem that we have.
Well,
I don't know what he means when he says
the breakdown of the family.
I think families have change.
So let's talk about two gay,
uh,
individuals who are now parents because
they can't get married,
they can adopt the kid.
Don't go to depot.
Well,
okay.
Well the reality is the family today
isn't the family of the 1950.
So when they say the breakdown of the
family,
what family are they talking about?
Single moms are as common as two family
households and are we to say that that's
a better structure?
So I'm not sure if even I buy into that
assertion that there's been some
breakdown.
I will agree.
There's been an evolution and families
look very different today.
Interracial families couldn't exist for
the 50 years ago.
Is that the breakdown of the family?
Because now you and I could be married
and have kids.
Is that no longer?
Well,
you know what,
that could be the new thing,
but you and I could decide to have a
child together,
right?
Sure.
Even though we're not married you in
vitro.
I mean there's so many ways that
families are created.
So when they say the breakdown,
what are they talking about it.
So I don't buy into that.
Alright,
good.
That's good to hear.
Alright,
so let's dive really into black lives
matter.
As a movement,
what do you make of the General Movement
itself?
Do you feel that it's,
it's hitting the right tone.
I'm going to say this and I'm going to
get just slaughtered on social media.
Oh my God.
Somehow I become like the spokesperson
for black lives matter,
even though,
you know,
they haven't enlisted me,
they haven't called me on the phone and
asked me to do it,
but I find myself trying to give some
context.
I think what black lives matter has done
has been nothing short of brilliant,
the issue of race and race politics in
this country,
very complex and all hands on deck.
So I play a role as a civil rights
attorney that represents families who
have been the victims of any kind of
police violence or they've had their
rights violated their constitutional
rights.
So I stepped in as a lawyer and I
represent those people.
But then I,
I have this platform,
it gives a talk on television every week
about these high profile cases.
So I get to lend my voice to that.
Then there are these people who go out
and they march and they protest and Hook
as a result of that.
So folks in the courtroom,
folks using their platform on
television,
uh,
folks like Al Sharpton using his voice
and then these protesters.
So now the issue of police profiling a
police shootings of African Americans,
it's been elevated to this national
level,
uh,
black lives matter have had audiences
with Hillary Clinton,
Bernie Sanders.
It's come up in the presidential debate
and I think we've got to give those
protests or some credit for that
because,
but for their activism,
this issue would not have become a part
of the national dialogue that we're
having about how do we make communities
safer?
What did,
what did you make of the instance when
the two protesters went up to Bernie's a
podium and basically grabbed the mic
from him?
He sort of let them do it because a lot
of people felt that that was like,
you know,
I talk about identity politics a lot and
that my problem with identity politics
is I find everyone has to figure out
who's the most aggrieved.
So your autumn,
Bernie is an ally obviously of the black
lives matter movement.
He's an ally of the other always.
But
if everyone is always looking out just
for themselves,
then you have the right in your mind to
grab the mic away from him.
Who even though he's as left as it's
gonna,
get in politics in America
now to say that I support what black
lives matter has done in terms of
elevating this conversation to a
national level.
It doesn't mean I agree with everything
that you do.
What I like for them to approach Bernie
differently.
Yeah.
Did I feel good about watching him try
to figure out what do I do,
do I call security,
do I have them escorted and then kind of
what's unfair about that.
He didn't have secret service
protection.
The reality is they wouldn't have even
gotten here that microphone or a stage
had that been Hillary Clinton or Donald
Trump or any of the other candidates
that trump has secret service,
but he has plenty of have security.
So the reality is Bernie in allowing
himself to be open,
kind of left himself open to these hyper
protest or so I didn't like that bottom
line.
I didn't like that,
but it doesn't take away from the
overall efforts that they've had and the
successes that they've had.
But I do think that we have to get
comfortable with this concept of
disruption and that's what I think is so
upsetting to a lot of people.
Even African Americans,
even traditional African American civil
rights leaders,
they want black lives matter to fit into
this box.
They want them to follow the mode of the
19 fifties and 19 sixties protestors.
And they're like,
hell no.
That's not who we are.
We're not looking for Martin Luther King
to come and save us and to lead us.
This is a movement of the people from
the people and it's being done totally
different.
So they.
They're not looking to organize in a way
that John Lewis and a lot of those civil
rights leaders did.
And I think that's a little unsettling
for people.
They don't get it.
Yeah.
So that's an interesting sort of
generational struggle.
Obviously John Lewis and Martin Luther
King and Malcolm x and many other people
did things at different levels,
some on the ground,
some via speaking and all that.
And I find that this movement hasn't
quite figured out what it is yet.
But I think your point is that that's
part of,
that's part of it,
part of the magic that's the part of
this new paradigm that literally you can
go on twitter and organize a thousand
people to show up at a rally and
sometimes at that rally it and my
daughter has been so there was a big
rally last year after Thanksgiving in
Los Angeles and she says,
mom,
some people had this sign.
Some people had that sign.
There was really no organization.
I'm not even sure if people knew why
they were there,
but he caught fire on facebook.
It caught fire on twitter and thousands
of people showed up and I says,
well,
you have to get used to that.
That's a part of the unorganized nature
of it is what makes it special and what
makes it unique.
And yes,
some people were there for gay rights,
some people were for human rights,
some people were there for sex
trafficking,
some people were there for police
brutality.
I said,
but they were all people who were at the
end of the day just trying to make their
lives,
their communities,
the people they care about have a better
quality of life.
So for that I have,
so interestingly there could be sort of,
this could be the genesis of setting
sort of much bigger because when you
take all those people,
and again this is where my thing with
identity politics is sort of interesting
because everyone's got their issue and
yet they're coming together so that's
good in itself,
but I'm afraid that that it allows for a
lot of issues to then just jump on top
of each other when some of these things
aren't necessarily connected,
but,
but what's the alternative?
And that's what I say to people.
Okay,
you don't like how black lives matter
has address this police brutality issue,
which by the way,
you have to give them some credit for
all of the legislation that's happening
at the federal level and state by state
requiring body cams.
California just passed a law now that
says a special prosecutor has to be
appointed if there is a police shooting.
So we,
we have seen the fruits of their labor
and I say to people,
give me an alternative.
What,
what in your worldview at or if you
could wave a magic wand,
how would it look?
Yeah,
I hear.
I,
yeah,
I don't think you're asking.
No,
I'm with you.
I find they're philosophically.
There's something to me that seems a
little dangerous if everyone sort of
jumping on the social,
the social justice things,
but I do hear you.
I don't,
I don't see anyone else.
And the black lives matter protesters
that you talk about generation.
They said Al Sharpton and some of these
other civil rights movements,
uh,
leaders,
what they do is fine.
They really are about grassroots there,
about local people,
indigenous leadership.
So people in their own communities
standing up and demanding that they get
a voice at the table when decisions are
being made.
Like who's going to be the police chief?
Who's going to be the district attorney
now,
what I would say is what I hope to see,
and I was disappointed in the midterm
elections last time.
How do we translate all of this social
activism into electoral politics?
How do we get those thousands of people
that showed up for a rally?
How do we get them to vote in the
election and beyond?
Yeah,
and you talk a lot about local politics.
So I can backing up for a sec.
I can't give you an example where I
think it's a bit of a problem.
So for example,
what we're seeing on college campuses
right now with free speech now I get
that the,
the thrust of what they're doing,
they're standing up for social justice
and they want equality.
We're not just talking about the black
community,
the gay community where whoever it is.
So I understand the idea there.
Uh,
but then when you see the instances like
at Yale where they're shouting down this
professor and that they're,
you know,
they're demanding professors be fired.
It seems to me that we've created a
situation here where the students are
now dictating the policy,
which it seems a little backwards and I
know that there's a lot of people in
academia that are,
that are really afraid of where this is
headed.
But they're 18,
they're 19,
and think about what,
what,
what should you be doing at college?
I think what those students are doing,
well you should exchanging ideas but not
demanding that professors be fired.
Why not?
If the professors are are racist and the
professors are not sensitive to the
issue of inclusion and diversity,
why not them that they'd be fired.
Did you feel that that professor at
Yale,
the,
the he,
he was the dean of that college and his
wife had written the letter about the
Halloween costumes.
I mean,
to me it was just,
you know,
if they don't want to.
Okay,
here's the problem for me
and any
transition,
anytime you're trying to transform an
organization that has had systemic
racial inequality and injustices for
decades,
is somebody going to get somebody going
to be sacrificed that perhaps really
wasn't the person?
Are they going to be scapegoated?
Probably.
Yeah.
But why is a university like University
of Missouri that all predominantly black
football team,
if they hadn't stood up and stood with
the guy,
Johnathan Butler,
who went on the hunger strike if they
hadn't stood up with those students?
I doubt
if Jonathan was still be on that hunger
strike,
I'll be dead by now.
I doubt that unit.
Right.
So in that case nobody responded so but,
but why is it a public,
university of Missouri,
like seven percent,
five percent,
such a low percentage of African
American students.
Why does it take us to get to the point
where the students have to shout down
the professors for the universities to
look at themselves and say there's
something wrong with this picture is not
reflective of the community where this
school is.
And you remember that University of
Missouri,
a president,
he's in his parade and he was so
arrogant and he wouldn't even address
those students.
So did he.
Did he end up stepping down?
They forced him out.
Absolutely.
So interestingly,
the Missouri and the yellow ones,
which happened basically at the same
time,
I see as to what,
to me at the Yale thing was,
was far worse than Missouri thing.
Yeah.
Had the mostly black football team not
got involved then nothing would have
happened.
So I do hear that.
But even in that instance,
you know,
there was that professor or a part time
professor,
that woman who came out and got caught
on camera saying we need some muscle
here and then that isn't.
That is a free speech issue.
So I guess that goes to your earlier
point,
which is you can be for a movement and
that doesn't mean you agree with every,
every tech,
some of the tactics are not well thought
out.
But again,
that's why I said they're 18,
they're 19 years old.
This is their first.
Some of them first experience with any
kind of unrest or any kind of protest.
So I wouldn't expect their thoughts to
be as developed by their tactics to be
as developed as you know,
somebody is 30 or 40 or beyond.
So I think we have to just accept that
these are teenagers just kind of finding
their way in and young adults who were
finding their way on some pretty complex
issues.
But I think more importantly for me is
if I'm a university president,
why,
why I'd be more proactive on these
issues.
Why aren't I addressing issues of
diversity and inclusion before it
bubbles up and now I have the kind of
protest that we've seen on campuses
across this country,
so I just don't think a lot of these
folks have been very smart about the
issue of diversity,
a diversity and inclusion,
and we could segue into the Oscars.
Very good example of that.
Let me throw in one other thing and then
we'll go ask,
but this is exactly why I wanted to talk
about this because I think that
basically the bulk of the same people in
the middle of this country pretty much
see these things in a similar way,
but even just what we're doing right
now,
it shows that there are,
there are different ways of looking at
it doesn't mean someone else's racist or
someone else's automatically a bigot or
something that we're so used to using
those words.
So that's,
that's why.
That's why I wanted to unfurl somebody
times.
Unfortunately we can't sit down.
Yeah.
Well that's what kind of dialogue
because those words that you use just
shuts the conversation down.
Yeah.
So one of one other piece on this and
then we'll move to the Oscars is my
guest last week,
Michael Shermer,
who is a thinker and a skeptic.
He made an interesting point about the
college thing where he said to me,
you know,
if these kids at Yale,
if at this point what they're protesting
about his halloween costumes that might
offend them,
then that actually shows great progress
in society because of the things that
they would have had to protest 30 years
ago.
And I thought that actually gave me a
little bit of a.
It was a nice feeling to sort of take
away from this that it doesn't mean that
problems don't exist,
but it means that we actually have moved
forward in society and we don't.
We don't.
I think sometimes we don't stop and
acknowledge.
Yeah.
And I think Obama did a great job of
that when they had the march on the John
Pettus bridge in Selma and he says,
as much work as there is to do on the
question of race in America,
we cannot lose sight of the tremendous
progress that has been made.
So I would agree with Michael on that
point that yes,
they weren't protesting because they
couldn't eat in the same cafeteria or
drink from the same water fountain as
the white students.
Now the issues of race and they've
changed.
They are there,
they're more subtle.
Uh,
they're more in some ways in city is
because they're not overt.
So the colored only signs made it real
clear what our mission was,
you know,
there wasn't much dispute about that.
But now you're right,
because even again,
African Americans are often divided on
this question and I've sat on drew's
couch with some conservative African
Americans who say like,
Larry,
what are they complaining about?
They,
they were in the college,
uh,
work hard,
get good grades and everything will work
out.
So the people aren't,
you know,
speaking from one voice on this issue of
race because it's important.
Yeah.
So I know I said last thing,
but I'm gonna throw in one more.
Just jumping off that.
So what,
what do you make in general of,
of black conservatives?
Because I'm friends with a few black
conservatives,
David Webb,
who's a Sirius xm host,
who is a Fox News contributor,
is a good friend of mine.
We worked together at Sirius and I know
that he,
I know him extremely well and I,
you know,
we've had drinks together.
We make dinner together.
I know that he believes what he's saying
and,
and when I see what people say about him
online,
you know,
uncle Tom and we could go through the
list of things that people say,
um,
wh,
what do you make of people like that?
First of all,
I think David and any black Republican,
conservative,
however they identify themselves,
they're perfectly within their right to
have the opinions that they have about
race and politics and,
and to identify with the GOP party or
the independent party or whatever party.
So I don't come from a place that
because you're black,
you have to agree with everything that I
believe in or because you're gay or you
know that there is no monolithic thought
in any of these communities.
That people have different points of
views.
And I like a conversation where all of
those points of views have an
opportunity to present themselves and to
be a part of the conversation.
I don't think that because David or
Larry or any of those conservatives have
their view about the family that that
view is any less significant than my
view because I don't see it the way they
see it doesn't mean that their points on
important.
So I like debating those guys.
I like talking to those guys and I think
it's a mistake to try to shut their
speech down or to try to silence them.
The silence who,
you know,
some people call these lefties,
these super progressive.
So no,
I,
yeah,
I'm not thrilled with those guys either,
but bring it on a whole other topic.
This is a perfect segway now to the
Oscars so white situation because Fox
News had stacey dash on who is black and
she was saying to the black community,
she was just like,
get over it that this is not an
important thing.
So that we have decided that we all take
a deal and give.
We will take you.
That's a fair trade.
Basically our number one white person
right now,
and you're good.
You can take.
Stacy was in one movie,
I think in 1995.
Clueless.
That's what we're getting.
Can we get a draft pick or we want to
Dale,
you know,
everyone wants a deal that was
on black twitter.
So just the power of social media space
is entitled to her opinion.
And I don't necessarily put stacy in
this category.
I don't know her personally,
but there are people of every race,
every persuasion that have branded
themselves as we started this
conversation as experts,
they like the attention that they get
from saying outlandish things that they
like to be provocative on topics.
I don't know if this is her,
like I said,
I know her personally,
but I do know because I sit in this
chair and I sit on these shows,
you know,
four or five times a week and some of
these folks I know that they're
intentionally trying to be provocative,
but she may believe that African
Americans should get over it.
I say again to her.
She's misguided in her thoughts and her
statements.
Uh,
and you have to look at the history.
None of this happens in a vacuum.
And for those folks who say,
or what about the naacp image awards,
they're all black.
And what about bt?
It's all black.
Why are white actors complaining about
that?
And I say,
well,
his look at the history,
why is there an NAACP?
Why are there Naacp Image Award?
Right?
I mean I,
look,
I have no problem with her saying
whatever she,
I,
if she believes it,
look,
even if she's just saying it to say it
because she's on television,
that's part of the game at some level as
you're saying.
And if she believes it,
then she believes it.
I thought the one part that was a little
odd really was that she said that we
shouldn't have a black history month,
which every part of our culture,
everything.
We should have a black history month and
we should have a Latino history month
then probably going to get history,
do away with everything that identifies
or a celebration.
Yeah.
One's culture.
Let's start with Columbus Day.
Alright.
So Oscar,
so white here.
So here we go.
So there is a big Brouhaha right now,
we got a Hashtag on twitter,
gone,
uh,
and a lot of the black community is not
happy about this.
Um,
I should say right up front that Chris
Rock,
the guy who's going to host the thing,
we said he's still going to host it is
black.
The president of the academy is Black,
but I think 94 percent of the voters are
white.
I hope I'm getting that 94 percent of
the academy.
The academy,
Seventy seven percent of the voters are
white male.
Yeah.
So okay.
So there are some numbers now.
I also saw some numbers that were that
since 2000 that pretty much it's been
about a that the black community America
is about 10 percent or about 12 percent
and they've gotten about 10 percent of
the nomination,
so that since 2000 that it basically
works out.
So I'm just throwing out some numbers to
start.
How do you feel about that?
So
I think that again,
I love protests.
Let me just start here.
You can tell that you're telling because
it works.
So Cheryl Boone Isaacs came out and said
change needs to happen,
but it needs to happen faster.
She was frustrated,
she was heartbroken.
A Jade Pinkett Smith did her facebook
video to her 7 million viewers a and we
have spike Lee make his statement and
guess what happened?
There was an emergency meeting on the
agenda was this issue of diversity for
the academy and out of that emergency
meeting came some commitments that were
pretty significant.
Like we're going to diversify our
membership by 20,
20,
we're going to add more women,
we're going to add more minorities and
we're going to make the issue of
diversity a bigger issue for the
academy.
And it makes sense.
You know,
I didn't tell you this,
I went to Harvard for law school,
but my major in college was economics.
So some of this stuff just boils down to
money.
So you want it to be an actress.
I'm an economics major.
So look at the facts here.
Last year they said the ratings down 16
percent and a lot of that was attributed
to last year when there were no black
nominees.
And that Hashtag trended Oscar.
So White,
the Oscars Cheryl,
they got a job to do it at the end of
the day,
they got to sell a television program to
one network and the network has to bring
in sponsors and advertisers to make a
lot of money.
So imagine if that 16 percent grew to 25
percent because high profile African
Americans like Spike Lee and will smith
and Marlon Wayans and Jaden Pinkett
Smith all said,
I'm not going to watch.
I'm not attending.
And to that point,
if there were more black people
nominated,
it's not like suddenly white people
would be like,
oh,
I'm not watching this.
There were some more black nominees is
ridiculous.
But do you think there's a little risk
though in that this is forgetting the
politics side of it and we know there's
plenty of politics in Hollywood,
but that these are subjective award,
so it is possible.
Do you think it is possible?
I should say that the people voted and
they just happened to the votes?
Just bullshit.
They just don't think that that's a
possibility.
Really?
Absolutely not.
Because what we're hearing is that the
membership,
they get to watch whatever movies they
choose to watch.
So if I'm a 78 year old white guy,
okay,
and I got all these movies to watch,
what are the chances that I'm going to
watch straight Outta Compton?
It's just not likely.
And here's what African Americans
wanted.
So That's interesting.
So that's not necessarily.
So that's almost,
you would say that sort of racist by
omission.
So there a bias.
That's why the city,
that's why diversity matters.
And some of us as well,
we don't want affirmative action for the
awards.
No,
we don't want affirmative action.
We just want the academy to reflect the
reality of movie goers.
So 46 percent of all tickets sold at the
box office from minorities.
So if the people buying your product,
by and large,
all we're saying is let the academy
reflect those people.
And at the end of the day,
if an African American or Latino decides
to straight Outta Compton,
isn't a movie that they want to vote for
it to be best picture of the year.
Okay.
We can live with that.
We're not asking them to get any special
treatment.
All we're asking for is diversity so
that at least there's some confidence
that the process is fair.
Even the plainfield don't give us any
greater advantages.
You know,
Viola David says is best the difference
between black women in TV and white
women are the opportunities,
so we're really just talking about
opportunities and spike Lee I think was
spot on saying this way before we get to
the award seasons.
This is happening in the c suites at
studios because when we look at who can
green light projects,
that's where we've got to start.
There's no diversity is no Africa.
I think he told me that.
I think he said there's one African
American that has the power to green
light a project.
So it starts with a major studio
project.
A major studio,
yes.
Obviously not independent films,
but it starts with those.
The number of and will be Goldberg,
talked about this on the view as a
director and an executive producer,
is that the black directors and writers
and producers,
they cannot get their projects through
mainstream studios and when they do,
their budgets are smaller and the
opportunities for success on those
projects,
but just again,
I'm going to go back to my economics,
right,
so yeah,
go to that.
You'll have straight out of compton
making $200,000,000.
You have ride along three pushing star
wars out of the top slot.
I think somebody ought to take note.
The bean counters,
the accountants,
the money people ought to be taking note
of that and and ought to do what TV has
done to recognize,
hey there's,
there's some money in these urban movies
and that's,
to me that's the interesting part
because if I know one thing about now
living in La and being part of the
Hollywood or whatever this is,
is that this town I think basically is
just run by people want to make money
that,
that it's a capitalistic town.
It's not like.
So your argument though,
would would prove if they said,
all right guys,
we're looking at the numbers here,
46 percent of the people that are coming
to movies are minorities.
Then we should be trying to increase
that percentage of the pie.
It's not going to come at the cost
necessarily have your white viewers that
I think the town would be would go for
that because they want to make money.
But I think that's the fear.
You hit on something really important
and we're seeing that in the
presidential election,
this fear that if,
if I make way for you African American
minority,
somehow that means there's no way for
me.
So your,
your success comes at my expense and
this is also what you should have
learned.
I'm sure you have about this town is
very relationship driven.
So if you,
if I don't have that relationship with
you,
I'm not necessarily even going to get in
the room to have the meeting and again,
to spike Lee's point if we don't have
more diversity in the top jobs and upper
level management in the decision making
positions than maybe I've never even in
the conversation.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
I saw our friend Larry Elder,
who we've mentioned a few times here,
uh,
I saw he was tweeting at spike and
basically was saying,
come on,
Spike.
You've made,
you know,
hundreds of millions of dollars.
You're selling your mansion in New York
for $35,
million bucks.
It's a little disingenuous for you.
Now I think I know what you're going to
say to this,
but I think it's interesting that it's
good at least that any community is
having those internal fight that.
But again,
look how ridiculous that argument is.
You can sit here and say,
Eva,
come on.
Your son
has autism.
So when you're standing up fighting for
more autistics are services for people
with autism.
That's just about enriching your own
son's life.
Oftentimes it's people's own personal
experiences that causes them to become
advocates or activists,
and it is because of spike Lee's
position inside the movie industry that
he has the voice and the credibility to
speak to it.
I surely don't have any credible voice
about making a movie.
I've never made a damn movie.
So who wants to hear from me about that?
You want to make a movie?
No,
I don't want to make a movie.
I want to talk about the folks that make
that better,
but I think his argument is disingenuous
and I think spike Lee is in the best
position and he's been on this point.
He's not new to this party.
If you look at the history of spike Lee,
Spike Lee will tell you lots of projects
he didn't get because he's always been
outspoken about this issue of race and
diversity and inclusion and yes,
he's made a lot of money and make more
of it.
Ironically,
spike is fighting the same fight in
reality that a lot of his movies were
about fighting made.
His moves are like,
he's coming out of nowhere with this and
he's hired,
and this is a statistic I didn't even
know until he got this a honorary Oscar
himself.
He's hired more African American actors
than any studio bar none.
So here's one guy who has not had,
you know,
a slew of blockbuster movies,
but yet he has made it a point to hire
more African American actors and he
accepted that award with Sam Jackson and
Denzel Washington or top actors,
black,
white,
green.
No matter what or you know,
and they were there because they have
been in so many of his movies.
You know,
it just hit me as we're talking about
this,
that it's so sad that so much has to be
framed within,
within the racial lens because we
haven't gotten it there because I've
had,
hey harry on my show who was the first
black woman to ever win an emmy.
And I remember watching when I was like,
I was probably 10 or 12 and I remember
thinking this woman is absolutely
hysterical.
I didn't look at her and think,
oh,
there's a black woman making me laugh.
I just thought this woman is hysterical
and I guess,
you know,
talent ultimately is what has to reach
the top,
but that doesn't mean that some of these
systemic things can't be.
And that's again,
that's where people were not talking per
se about affirmative action,
but people I think get that wrong.
We're not asking that you lower the
standards.
We're asking that you even the playing
field.
And that's a very big difference.
What would you say to the people,
I've seen this bubble up a little bit
lately,
that people are saying,
well,
if you look at the Latino community
there,
there are numbers in America versus
their nominations or the Asian community
really,
uh,
that they,
they never get nominated basically.
So I see a lot of people saying,
well,
the black community is fighting the
wrong fight here.
They're fighting something that makes
everyone else go.
You're fighting about Oscars.
Nobody cares about Oscars while the
Latino community is way less represented
in.
That is a fantastic
question.
And I knew I'd get one right.
Look at the history.
What do black people do?
We break the damn doors down.
So everybody else,
the gays,
the Latinos,
the Asians,
women can walk through the door.
So watch what happens when diversity
happens is,
and I got to just be about black actors.
It's going to be about diverse actors.
It's going to be Latinos,
Asians,
people with disabilities.
They will all benefit.
Somebody has to lead on this,
and if you look historically,
it's been African Americans who've been
willing,
even though you're right,
disproportionately our numbers are much
smaller than Latinos,
but we have a much more organized and
developed a system of protesting and
raising issues of racial inequality in
this country than Latinos and Asians.
And Trust me,
when we break the doors down,
nobody else is saying,
oh my God,
they broke that damn door down.
I'll watch that door is too broken.
Watch everybody run through that door.
So I would say to Latinos,
Asians stand up with us.
We all benefit from this.
We're not saying that it's all black
actors.
I want us,
I'm a woman.
I want to see more females.
I want to see I'm a disability rights
advocate.
I want to see more individuals with
disabilities portrayed in movies.
And television,
so I think nothing but good from any
marginalized group comes from the
efforts of what we see happening on this
Oscar.
So white.
Yeah,
in a way it shows the strength of the
black community actually because because
a lot of what we care about culturally
and the music we listened to and all of
that stuff comes from the black
community.
So it's like in a way that the black
community has the lead on this for the
other minorities.
So it does kind of make sense.
And for those folks that say,
Oh my God,
you know,
this is a bunch of millionaires fighting
about a gold statue.
Who Cares?
The Oscars are a very important
institution and the entertainment
industry,
particularly in a state like California
is huge.
And again,
if we're buying 46 percent of the
tickets at the box office,
this is an issue that we need to be
aware of.
Does it mean that we don't care about
hunger?
poverty and the poverty and the fact
that,
you know,
one out of three black kids live in
poverty,
you know,
and what our capacity is large enough
that we can fight the fight on poverty
as well as address issues at the Oscars.
I don't see them as mutually exclusive
at all.
Yeah.
All right.
Well let's,
let's go with the poverty thing for a
little bit because,
uh,
one of the things that I've seen lately
is that a lot of numbers are showing
that the black community has not gotten
any better economically under the seven
years of Obama.
And you know,
people felt,
you know,
he wanted to sort of be a post racial
president.
I don't think we've quite got there.
Not necessarily his fault.
Um,
but what can the black community do to
get those numbers?
Well,
don't necessarily agree with those
statistics.
I think they're there.
If you,
depending on what you read,
the economy overall is much better under
Obama.
Millions more.
However,
the economy itself at the economy itself
is,
but that the black community still
behind in that sort of regroup the black
community has made some gains under
Obama.
So again,
I disagree with and,
and I reject those statistics that say
blacks are worse off under Obama than
they were under George Bush.
Hello?
I don't think so.
Uh,
do we still have a ways to go in this
country?
Absolutely.
Are we still a disproportionately
impacted by a criminal justice system?
Yes.
Are we still lagging behind in wages,
a in asset accumulation?
Absolutely.
So there is a lot of work to be done,
but that doesn't dismiss the great work
that President Obama has done on
healthcare.
A look at the jobs,
the unemployment rate lower than it's
been in a decade.
Uh,
so I,
I think we have to celebrate those pro,
you know,
the,
the advances that have been made and
keep fighting and just overcoming
hundreds of years of systemic racism.
Obviously what we are now seeing doesn't
happen overnight.
It is a long and entrenched fight that
is,
I think,
what we learned more attractable than
perhaps what we thought.
I don't think anyone thought that
Obama's legacy,
you know,
the hope we were all high on hope.
Here's a were on hold and no one could
have predicted that the rancor and the
adversarial nature of what he has faced,
particularly in these last three years.
I,
I know,
I couldn't imagine that and saw that and
it's hard to say.
Is that,
is that racial,
is that that our system is just warped
wood.
Would the Republicans have been more
willing to work with a white president?
I hate bringing everything down to that.
To that point.
There may be some element of it.
I don't.
I don't think we really know.
I don't think we know.
I don't think we can ever.
And again,
I get so beat up about this,
but it's just what I know just
historically,
I'm,
I'm a student of history.
A race matters in this country and no
matter whether you're the president of
United States or you're the president of
the Oscars,
the fact that we're still fighting these
battles have to tell us that race still
matters.
So.
All right,
well let's go.
How about we get away from Raytheon?
It's just,
it's such a shame that we have to spend
so much time talking about it,
but that,
that is the point,
I suppose.
Uh,
so let's talk about politics because
politics thing too.
You are supporting Hillary.
I am supporting Hillary Clinton.
I'm also supporting a slew of
progressive and some female,
mostly female candidates.
I'm a big proponent of,
of inclusion,
not just for race,
for women,
for lgbt,
for Latino's.
I just think this country works better.
Our state,
our city,
our county,
when we have diverse voices.
So I support a lot of candidates at the
local,
state and national level that don't look
like traditional candidate.
So what do you make of the Hillary
campaign?
Because I've,
I'm not sure who I'm supporting at this
point.
I'm really still,
I've become a really at this point.
I see myself as a real centrist and I'm
just not sure now,
it seems to me that Hillary and Bernie
are way better than any Republican
debates,
uh,
have been about substance,
you know,
they've really,
even with the gun thing,
you know,
Hillary's trying to pin Bernie as the
gun guy.
Meanwhile he got a d minus from the NRA,
but so it's really been about substance.
The Republicans,
it's trunk,
it's silliness.
We can talk about that too.
Um,
but one thing I have seen with Hillary's
that to me,
this campaign,
because of the email stuff and then
guys,
he,
which finally that's going away,
but whatever it is,
but there is no,
there hasn't been a point where it's
been like a run,
like a nice,
like month long run where this is about
really feeling good and maybe that's the
media doesn't like her.
I don't think the media really likes or
something.
But how do you feel about the campaign
in general?
So here's what I think.
I think the trump and the outsider
voices that have dominated the news
media isn't just impacting glp and the
Republicans.
It's also impacting dims as well in
Bernie is lining up as that outside
voice,
and Hillary of course is the mainstream
establishment candidate.
When you listen to what Bernie and
Hillary are saying,
knowing what we now know about Obama,
Bernie's policies,
they just don't have a snowball's chance
in hell of ever coming to fruition.
He's talking about a 90 percent tax rate
on the rich.
Hello,
rich guys in Congress as Senate are
going to vote for 90 percent tax rate on
that snow jumping because I know people
are going to be yelling at you over that
because I've mentioned that and people
have said to me what he's saying is that
it will be a progressive tax,
so it's not that you're being taxed
fully on the 90 percent increase on the
rich.
It doesn't play well to Congress
because most of those guys are rich
guys.
He's talking about eliminating obamacare
as single source,
single payer source healthcare system.
We couldn't get that voted in even when
the congress was controlled by Dims,
so I like his fire.
I like his progressive politics,
but I'm a pragmatist at heart and I just
don't think any of those things he could
get accomplished and we don't need eight
more years of not being able to get
anything accomplished.
What I like about Hillary is she setting
me on fire.
Am I as high as I was eight years ago
when I don't have any of that,
but at the core of me I like getting
stuff done.
I think the woman can get shit done and
you talk about the in Gaza and the
emails.
To me,
the crowning joy of her campaign was
sitting at those hearings for a moment.
The way they attacked her,
it would have taken Mother Teresa
herself to too restrain some of these
junior just got to Congress five days
ago,
don't know where the bathroom is.
People yelling at her about the most
ridiculous and unimportant details and
she just sat there.
I so I'm with you 100 percent.
That that was not only was her best,
that to me was like,
you should be the president.
Just for that.
I posted a really funny line.
Did you see there was a moment where she
did this little thing,
she was like,
it was like drop the mic and it was like
vote.
That's the kind of level headed
toughness that you need an office and
that's what,
to me,
Bernie,
when Bernie is doing all that,
I'm like,
dude,
okay,
you got to bring it down a notch.
You yelling,
I can't really understand you.
You're making it.
You're giving me a headache.
So it's interesting because I know so a
lot of my audience loves Bernie and I've
said several times that me and my heart,
I like Bernie the best.
I liked the ideas the best,
but I also,
because I consider myself a pragmatist
when he saying these things,
sometimes I see what he tweets these
really lofty things about,
you know,
it's all about changing the system.
I'm all for changing the system and
getting money out of politics and all
those things.
But we just had Obama tried to change
the system pretty intensely too and we
were all higher than seven years ago.
Right.
So that's,
that's why at this point I sort of think
I'm mostly begrudgingly
supporting hillary too,
because here's the problem with that,
and I tried to tell people this with
Obama.
Nobody would listen to me.
Then he says to me that that's okay,
that's fair.
That's why my clients pay me a thousand
dollars,
but no,
we have a two party system and the
president is here.
He can do nothing.
She can do nothing without the congress
and the Senate.
You can be the most Charisse,
you cannot bend more charismatic than
Obama.
The guy is like swag on steroids,
but that doesn't mean anything in
Washington DC.
And that's the problem with all these
people following trump.
Trump is not going to be a dictator.
We don't have a dictatorship in our
government.
Our government is about,
it's a collaborative and if you're not
able one to understand that and then to,
to navigate that,
you get nothing done.
So that's the crazy part and where it
goes to in this I think is probably a
throughline of everything we've said
here is that education is the most
important part.
We have.
We have three branches of government.
People forget that we have a judicial
branch.
They decide what's legal.
We have a legislative branch.
They decide to make laws and then we
have all these policies,
these,
these
glp candidates are talking about.
They're gonna build a wall and they're
going to hell how exactly you're going
to do that.
So that to me is the most dangerous part
of this for a second,
because I saw him say a week ago or two
weeks ago,
he said something like,
when I'm president,
you know they're going to put a merry
Christmas back on starbucks card or
something like that.
Now I get it.
It's just a stupid.
He's just throwing stupid red meat out
to some morons,
but like even that it shows,
it shows a inclination to not even
really understand what the role of the
president is
dummied down.
If you watch those gop debates,
I'm sitting there,
they're foreign.
When Ben Carson said,
see my mother,
she used to drive a car until the car
wouldn't drive anymore.
Then she would take her pennies and
she'd buy a new car.
Well,
he is supposed to translate to economic
policy of the world hard.
Her pennies do well on ice as well.
They said,
well you one of the questions like when
you can't bomb these,
these,
these vehicles,
because they have civilians.
Well just tell them if they ride in the
car,
they're going to get bombed so they
shouldn't get in the car.
So that's the,
that's the piece.
That's a piece.
Yeah.
I mean look,
that's not a policy.
What Isis is stupidity.
And that's the piece that goes across
both sides because.
So you hear that right?
Did you hear Ben Carson?
And it's like you clearly know nothing
about foreign policy.
Like he just uses a couple of buzzwords,
Caliphate Jihad.
He just puts a couple words together,
but then I'll hear Bernie talk about it
and I'm not for war.
I'm certainly not for nation building
and all of that stuff.
But I hear him say,
well,
you know,
we're gonna have to work with our
allies,
do this.
But.
But he,
he also will say I'm never for war,
which means that there's no threat of
anything too.
So it's like both sides are playing.
Okay.
That's the scary part.
And that's what I think the worst thing
about the trump reality show is it has
dummied down the conversation so that
we're starting to believe that these
bluster is,
you know,
blow horns can go in with these
simplistic solutions to these complex.
I mean the,
the problems are so complex.
So his whole Muslim policy,
do you know that the people who are
fighting isis the most are Muslims?
So when you insult for Muslim community,
you insulting our outside.
But if you don't know anything about
foreign policy,
you don't know that.
And now what's really scary me as
they're saying,
when trump becomes the gop nominee,
he's got an now somehow figure out how
to reverse himself.
You know,
he's insulted African Americans,
Latinos and Muslims,
just about every group that you need to
win the general election in this
country.
So now he's got to walk that.
But how do you walk that back?
And here's his dilemma.
If he walks it back,
those white lower middle class men
mostly who were supporting him,
they're going to be,
they're going to be passed because the
reason they like him is because he's
standing up to make America great.
I eat white again.
So how do you embrace the immigrant
population in the Muslim population
without alienating your base?
And that's the stupidity of the GOP
party did me?
Yeah.
You know,
it's interesting.
This is where I've been very critical of
the left because I think that the
progressive's because they.
So their intentions usually are very
good,
but they're so their knee jerk responses
to yell bigot or racist or homophobic or
sexist or whatever it is at everybody
that they.
In a way they've enabled trump because
they've silenced so many centrists and
so many liberals that I think they've
enabled will then trump just comes in
with answers instead of saying instead
of a real debate where we say,
what are we really doing with
immigration right now?
What are we really doing about refugees
and migrants?
Trump just comes in and says,
Hey,
I'm banning everybody and then that
sounds good.
So I partly do blame our side of the
aisle on that because we haven't,
we haven't dealt with it well,
a narrow group of people that he plays
too.
But I.
One of the things I find most
interesting about the glp election,
remember after Mitt Romney lost,
they went and did this exhaustive audit.
How did we lose?
So let's dissect it,
let's analyze and figure out what
happened.
And what they concluded was they did not
Garner enough votes from the minority
voters,
particularly Latinos,
and that they had to become the party of
inclusion.
And so,
and in all their big money donors said,
we're no longer supporting any of these
kooks.
We want candidates that can win.
We're going to put our money behind
candidates that can win and we're going
to go out and become the party of one.
And they've done the exact opposite
front runners,
not runner runners have made the concept
of inclusion like a joke.
Yeah.
And that's clearly why trump is.
The party is against trump.
Alright.
So one last thing before we wrap up.
I do want to talk a little bit about
your son and your activism in with
autism and the things that you've
written and things like that.
So we hear a lot about autism,
but I don't think people really
understand what it is or how many people
are now affected by autism.
Not only the,
the kids that have it,
uh,
but the families and all that.
So in just a couple minutes,
can we just do like a autism one?
Oh
yeah.
Quickly.
So autism is a neurological disorder
impacts three major areas.
Your communication,
your ability to learn.
So your cognition and then your social
skills.
One in 64 children.
Some say that number's understate.
It could be as high as one in 34,
one and 35,
but the CDC number is one in 64 children
have autism boys four times more likely
than girls to have autism.
So it impacts the fastest growing
childhood disorder in America.
Probably not possible for you to not
have a friend,
a coworker,
a family member of someone in your
circle that's been impacted by autism.
My best friends.
So spectrum disorder.
So that means you meet one person with
autism,
you've met one person with autism,
because every child,
every adult is impacted differently from
some very high functioning folks who you
might've heard the term asperger's
disorder,
a false side,
Bill Gates allegedly have asperger's
disorder to people who are so low
functioning that term low functioning,
and I don't mean it in a pejorative way,
but who have no verbal skills have to be
in some kind of group home or very
restrictive environment.
A huge,
huge push was made in the last decade to
address issues of adequate diagnosis and
intervention.
Again,
statistically African Americans,
Latinos diagnosed two to four years
later than their typical peers.
Really difficult time accessing
services.
Now the focus and the push is on the
aging out.
So a lot of the kids that were diagnosed
10 years ago,
20 years ago,
are becoming teens and young adults.
So the question of college employment
and independent living.
So there's been kind of a shift in the
community or there's this slowly the
shift is happening to focus on what do
we do with this population of teens and
young adults.
So if people want to find out more,
where can we find out quick about my
work?
Uh,
uh,
Riva,
Martin Dot Com and then the nonprofit
that I started,
especially with these network,
especially news network,
that org.
All right,
well it's been an absolute pleasure.
We did the long form thing.
I mean I literally didn't pick up my
notes so that,
that is a good conversation.
All right,
so I want to thank her eva Martin and
you can check out more of her work as
you just said at Arriva Martin Dot Com
and we will do it again next week.
Thanks guys.